today the organizers of life is
beautiful release the highly anticipated
music lineup
the three-day celebration will take over
the streets of downtown las vegas this
september
rocky theaters joining us now to give us
a look at the star
power hey rocky that is right with more
than 60 of the world's most influential
artists on the lineup
life is beautiful is sticking to what
they're known for unifying with their
diverse musical performances
so let's start with the headliners we've
got pop star billy eilish the five-time
grammy award winner is back
for her second life is beautiful also
headlining rock and roll hall of famers
green day and psychedelic phenom tame
impala new to the life is beautiful
scene though rapper asap rocky og rapper
ludacris
and electronic music star illinium
artists like don toliver emotional
oranges no osiris and glass animals will
also be taking the stage so
there's a little something for everybody
for a full list just head to
lifeisbeautiful.com where you can also
find out more about tickets of course
those will be released friday march 12th
at 10 a.m
general admission prices are going for
around 300 but if you want the vip
experience
it's going to cost you those tickets
range from about 680 bucks
and around to around three thousand
dollars
it's worth it though i promise the
festival director said health
safety and security comes first but
there will be a heightened sense of
responsibility for the entire team
as they work with city officials to
ensure a safe and fun return
of live music back to you that is
awesome we've been waiting things rocky